Speaker 1: All right, let's start today with
a sort of comprehensive covid update.
You know, last week I told you that covid
cases were down in the United States on average,
about 20 percent per day from their Delta
peak.
And we laid out a few possibilities as to
why the numbers look that way.
So to remind you, the things we talked about
last week were vaccination is responsible,
more vaccination, fewer cases, OK, some natural
seasonality being responsible, even though
it's not exactly lining up with the typical
flu season, that there seems to be some kind
of peaks and valleys seasonality to covid.
So many infections have gotten us closer to
herd immunity, combined with vaccination that
has been suggested.
And then also sort of the most nefarious explanation
is cases aren't actually going down.
It's reporting has become less reliable.
Some states maybe aren't even being honest
about cases.
And then at the end of last week's segment,
we said, well, let's wait and see if this
trend continues.
The trend has continued.
And in the last week, the numbers have dropped.
Even more U.S. cases per day are down now
31 percent relative to the Delta peak.
The Delta peak was about one hundred and sixty
six thousand cases per day.
We're now down to one hundred and fourteen
thousand cases per day.
Now, this is still like a wild, crazy number,
but a 31 percent decline is notable for sure.
Now, last week, we didn't know whether deaths
were declining.
And what I mean by that is that deaths tend
to lag cases by three to four weeks.
And since last week, we were about three weeks
into the case decline.
We saw deaths level out, but we just didn't
know our deaths really starting down.
Are they on the way down?
We now have another week of data and we can
see that, yes, deaths are declining in the
United States, down about 11 percent on average
from the Delta peak.
It's not that much, but it is now clearly
the direction.
The Delta peak was about 850 cases per day,
roughly half of the thirty nine hundred cases
I'm sorry, deaths per day that we saw at the
biggest peak of the pandemic so far.
So Delta peak deaths peaked at 1850 down to
sixteen fifty.
Still a horrifying, unconscionable amount
of death, basically half of a 9/11 every single
day.
But you'd rather see the numbers going down
rather than up.
Now, one other thing that we should be looking
at is whether what's going on in the United
States seems to follow or track what's happening
globally.
If cases were going down in the U.S. but up
everywhere, we might say, well, maybe our
reporting is wrong or maybe maybe something
just doesn't make sense because we saw, you
know, Delta came to Europe and then it came
to the U.S. and things seem to sort of move
in tandem, adjusting for vaccination rates.
Of course, the U.S. Delta wave down thirty
one percent from its peak globally.
Cases are also down about the same, about
30 percent decline in cases globally.
And then very important as well, global deaths
since the peak of Delta also declining by
about 25 percent, which you really like to
see now within the United States, we have
clearer and clearer, clearer data about the
political alignment of this Delta wave.
We've talked about this before and we continue
to get very interesting new data.
Check out this incredible graphic, which I
will describe if you're not watching today.
This is a plot of covid deaths per capita
against how pro Trump or pro Biden, a state
was in twenty twenty.
So if a state voted Biden over Trump by 20
points, it's more pro Biden than if Biden
won by, say, 10 points.
OK, now, if you're looking at this graph,
you can see that the states with the lowest
per capita death rates as of September 2013,
14 day average.
So we're talking now in September.
You see that it's the heavy Biden states with
the lowest death rate, Vermont, Massachusetts,
Maryland, California, to a lesser degree,
you know, places that are slightly pro Biden,
like Illinois, Nevada, where Biden won, but
not by as much.
The slightly Trump states are then doing even
worse in terms of covid death.
So like Texas, for example, Florida, and then
you get into the absolute worst states with
the highest average per capita death rates
in September.
These are the heaviest Trump states.
We're talking about Alabama, West Virginia,
Mississippi, etc..
So as we've said before, as we've seen before
in the data, we don't just say it, we say
it.
If we see it in the data, trump voting in
twenty twenty.
Predicts covid death rates now that vaccines
have been widely available for some time and
that we know how you reduce the amount of
spread.
This is not really a mystery.
And when you look at the United States and
look at the least vaccinated states, it's
essentially all red states.
It's Idaho, West Virginia, Wyoming, followed
by Mississippi, North Dakota, Alabama, Tennessee,
Indiana, Louisiana.
You then get to Ohio, which is sort of, you
know, closer to 50 50.
Ohio, a swing state in many elections at 54
percent.
Vaccination, I think you get the picture.
So the overall story here is cases and deaths
declining in the US cases and deaths declining
globally, vaccination going up globally and
in the U.S.
The states that are doing the best are the
most vaccinated states, which are Biden states.
There's really no new information in that
sense, but this is the trend as of the last
few weeks in the United States.
So let's hope it continues.
Let's hope it gets better everywhere.
And we'll report back in another week or so
and see if the decline continues.
If this decline were to continue in six weeks,
we would be an amazingly great shape.
Caveat, I said the exact same thing in February
where we said if these declines continued,
there would be no covid in like six weeks.
That's rarely the way that it goes.
So we'll continue to track the numbers and
see where we end up.